ah
first day of autumn so i mean what the
heck else was i gonna call the live
stream
let me
fine tune the angle because i always do
uh it was once a singer-songwriter named
warren
zep went past me warren
zev he was known for producing songs
that were both lighthearted and macabre
such as werewolves of london never heard
of i haven't heard of him but i do know
werewolves of london
i have that hang on that's a little
better
um i put that song on a
mix from my kiddo of wolf
songs that she really likes wolves
forgive me for a second i'm going to
tink around with the lighting setup for
a hot minute
nope matt that's a lot
let's dial that back
i can work with that i think
new toys
uh i'm in britain so i'll say good
morning oh good yeah
it is uh it would be the am over there
wouldn't it
as we say in england what are you doing
in my house you lunatic just here for a
little sugar for the tea
i'm lying i don't put sugar in my tea
ah hey dude hey ms wicketwolf
ah good to see
everybody here
what's your uh who's your favorite
member of the torchwood team
i don't know they're all kind of
terrible people
like i want to say jack but i don't like
jack nearly as much when he's on
torchwood
i love jack when he's on doctor who when
he's on torchwood he's so
pretty he's not fun it's part of my
problem with that show
they're all awful like all of them are
terrible terrible human beings
like they function well enough as a team
but i don't think i actually like
any of them
uh congrats on coming out as trans and
happy first day of fall
thank you castile i mean like given that
i do
lump gender fluid in under the
trans umbrella you know i do consider
myself to have been out as trans but you
know
obviously for some folks taking the um
the he pronoun off the board and no
longer having that as an option i mean
it's a step it's a journey and that's
another thing like i don't want to be
clear i don't want people to think that
like
that was me coming out with something
i'd been hiding
that that was me
realizing where i already was but like
this is a journey
this is like the whole thing for me uh
in particular
is that i i'm not discovering who i've
always been
is who i actually am is
continually changing and evolving
process so you know
if you met me ten years even five years
ago
you know this wasn't hiding
underneath who i was presenting as
i was a different person and now i'm
this person
ah dark water death in heaven review
tomorrow any spoilers
i personally wish i liked the episode
more than i did well first thing to let
you know ben
for the take two uh reviews i'm actually
um suspending my my normal rule of
treating two-parters as a single story
because my original reviews of those
episodes are
each one individually that's also how
i'm gonna do the take two reviews so
tomorrow
is only dark water death in heaven next
week it's been 45 years since the rock
band heart released their debut adam
dreamboat annie for a debut
album it sounds fantastic and never
really got into them as a band
how's life it is not too bad
um i went and visited a friend today who
i haven't seen in a long time
we had to stay six feet apart i i
i hung out on her deck you know didn't
go in our house we both had mass so you
know slightly compromised but
it was nice it was nice to see her it
was nice to hang out
uh happy to be chilling on one of these
streams oh it's great to see you zandir
i'm not gonna be here for long just
gonna pop in and out i love the mug have
a good night oh well thank you very much
i found out on sunday that i'm going to
be an on for the first time well
congratulations
that that is one thing i will never
actually be because i'm an only child
so i love your recent pirate cosplay
picture it was ours
thank you ian i had a lot of fun doing
that i've
i've been sticking to my sort of
commitment to set time aside to mess
around with
my costumes and my outfits and you know
to not just have that stuff
linger in the um
in the closets
uh love your harley quinn by the way
yeah same deal
that's what i haven't done that makeup
in a long time
that's another thing like i really
if i was more dedicated and or had more
money to throw at
at added i'd like start learning more
elaborate makeup
than what i've traditionally been doing
but
i'm not sure i have the patience for it
and i know i don't have the money to buy
a ton more makeup than what i already
have
so you know
uh have you seen the one division
trailer just finished editing my
reaction i was genuinely speechless yes
if you pop on over to the break room of
geeks you will see my you will see my
live reaction
uh to that trailer
tasha isn't awful as tosh isn't great
i for like first of all realize it's
been a long time
since i've gone back and revisited
torchwood
um because i don't wanna um like the one
time i did somebody paid me
but you know tash tosh is comparatively
less terrible but she never struck me as
a particularly good person
either i mean again faded memories
to be fair
personal favorite was either tasha yanto
i wanted to like yanto but honestly
cyberwoman made him an idiot
like how flippant stupid
not going there for torchwood the most
random thing was gwen and owen making
out in season one
yeah season one had a lot of
stuff like that you make a cute harley
quinn no thank you very much
do you think there's any chance of the
bbc ever remastering the first four
seasons of doctor who in hd
i mean i have absolutely no idea i don't
know what it would take
to be able to do that is the thing i
don't know enough about
technology to know how viable it is to
be able to take the footage they have
and scale
it up in that manner i don't know how
feasible it is
but given that no whether it's feasible
or not it's going to
cost something like let's be honest
way fewer people buy classic than new
in general and even fewer of them shell
out for
first doctor if we're really going to
crunch the numbers on it so
like from a cost perspective it may not
be worth it
for how many they'd actually sell
especially considering a lot of the
people who would theoretically want it
would already have
those same stories on like dvd or
something that is in hd
and so only a sliver of that sliver is
going to shell out to buy it a second
time just to get an hd
i mean if they if they can i would like
them to that'd be great
do i expect them to not really like i'm
not gonna rule it out but i wouldn't
hold my breath for it
we experienced one of the greatest
losses in the whole buffy verse in
angel season 5 a brave individual and
staple of the show
a moment of silence for spike's coat
well it ain't getting any better
joining you with apple cider always
seemed like the more appropriate thing
for september
i will say pumpkin for october
that absolutely works i love your doctor
who christmas mug thank you very much
when i was in college since candles were
banned i made a paper menorah
with pictures of the first eight doctors
and the tardis
in the middle i love that
have you seen the netflix movies cuties
nope and i don't really
care to like i know the controversy
around it which
from what i understand about the what
the movie is actually doing is stupid
and misplaced
but like it's not the kind of movie that
i have any interest
in regardless of controversy so that
gets filed under
unless somebody pays me i'm not gonna
watch it
let's see
oh my goodness i've fallen so far behind
on questions already
that happened fast an effort to
contribute
non-doctor who question ooh ambitious of
you uh do you have any trans head canons
you want to talk about
oh hmm
not off the top of my head
i'd have to i'd have to sit and ponder
that one and like
really go through it like i i never had
any that i like
really latched on to otherwise it would
have popped to the front of my head
there'd probably been some at some point
over the years but
i always thought the youtube algorithm
was strange found your council of geeks
channel before i even knew there was a
vera channel well i mean like to be fair
to the algorithm
i updated the vera channel way more
sporadically
so you know
to me it makes sense it's all news by
now but gallifrey 1 has been postponed
to 2022
i'm it's not surprising i've long
accepted that would be the case just
waiting for official confirmation
yeah yeah that is a bummer do you
cosplay yes i have a number of cosplays
uh can't you be an aunt via your
partner's siblings well
my current partner is also an only child
and
has no kids so you know
my daughter's mother
does have siblings but like i've never
i've never felt like an aunt or i guess
earlier days would have been an uncle
but i i've never
i felt like i was i was i always felt
like
the person who was there that the kids
got along with okay like i don't
i mean i don't know i don't know what it
feels like to be
that i guess i don't know
uh so have you separated dark water and
death in heaven just because of how you
did it originally as opposed to thinking
they didn't fit together like with the
season five finale
i know it's not because they didn't fit
together and well
actually can i tell you the truth the
actual reason i'm doing them one at a
time
is because my thumbnail guy
joel he did all the thumbnails for
series eight all at once
and he did them individually for dark
water and death in heaven
and i was going to send him a message
saying like hey
can you combine these i'm gonna do them
together but then i stopped and thought
about it and was like well
the um original reviews
were dealing with these two separately
maybe the new ones should too so like i
stand by that decision but the idea of
doing it all
was kind of sparked by my thumbnail
artist so i find that amusing do you
watch chick flicks not much
that's not really my uh my particular
cup of tea
the other thing i'm bummed about uh gali
is not being able to celebrate my 30th
birthday there but i will do something
special oh well i'm
i hope you you still have fun with
whatever you choose to do
uh you aren't an only child
you always have an evil twin you can
blame things on
uh see that that's the thing i am the
evil twin
ah is it all right that i went through a
journey of gender discovery and end with
the conclusion that i'm cis
no that not only is that
all right that is wonderful
like i'm honest to god i okay
ah there's this whole thing within the
trans community right now about this
idea of trans
trenders people who are being
transferred attention and part of the
reason i
hate that concept especially as a
derogatory term
is because people should have the
freedom to explore their gender
identity and their sense of self and who
they are even
if the destination they ultimately
arrive at is the same place they started
because going through that journey can
still be good for you
sometimes you have to take this long
trip to realize oh
i was where i needed to be all along
sometimes you have to go to oz in order
to realize there's no place like home
and that's fine it's absolutely fine
so yes yes it is
all right and i am happy for you and i
am so glad
that you told me that thank you thank
you very much
what are your thoughts on friday the
13th and nightmare on elm street of
dealing with the two originals as films
under themselves
nightmare on elm street certainly holds
up better friday the 13th was
trailblazing at the time you know but
not not so much now nightmare on elm
street still has some
some interesting things going on even
now i think especially in the
visuals on a budget department
check out dream sounds if you want a new
channel they analyze disney music
through
queer lens ooh
remind me of that like on twitter or
something because i'm gonna have
forgotten by the time we get to the end
of this stream
atd it's a reality but that sounds
interesting
there's a girl named alicia who's been a
lifelong family friend i had the
privilege to attend her wedding on
saturday
it was one of the happiest things i've
ever experienced all year ah that's
great connor
not gonna lie i wanna vision looks good
but of the three mcu tv shows we have
footage for i'm more excited for loki to
be honest i couldn't care less about
falcon and winter soldier
i mean i'm about equally at least
interested
in them what are your thoughts on the
movie splash if you haven't seen it on
disney plus i've never seen it at all
didn't see it when i was young haven't
seen it now
i have no thoughts
i gave up on watching torchwood after
the dog pissing the tent story
see i don't even remember that bit i
almost gave up after the second episode
day one
oh that episode's terrible it's
so bad uh what are your thoughts on
three men and a baby haven't seen it
this reminds me of the wonderful pose
saying the heavy tone of cyber woman
versus the hilarity of cyber titties
yeah that's series one torch put in a
nutshell
boy it's a mess uh biggest doctor who
missing episode hopes i mean the rest of
uh
10th planet would be nice
do you ever watch the misfits nope how
would you describe bob owen kurt as an
actor and as an individual i don't know
know him as an individual he seems to be
a perfectly fine actor
uh for a long time i've said a buffy and
torchwood crossover would be amazing and
it would however
uh what about a buffy crossover with the
umbrella academy now that one i'd be
interested to see
like to see willow give uh vanya some
tips on sort of getting a handle on
herself
uh the original our 360 quality not sure
three and hd mastering would not make it
look
worse well okay so talking about the
very early
doctor hoover's that that we do have
there are probably ways to make it
better but like
with something that low-res it's
probably going to be meticulous and
again
expensive um
do you think dark crystal could get
picked up by another streaming service i
doubt it
i mean the thing is ultimately and why i
figured the show probably
was gone
that level of puppetry is expensive
like that's that's just the reality of
it and i can't imagine that
too many of the other streaming services
are going to be prepared to throw the
money at the thing
that netflix did i mean maybe
disney plus but they've never shown any
interest in
that end of the henson stuff they really
only seem to care about the muppets so
is it impossible no would i love it to
happen yes do i think it will
no emperor's new groove quote yes indeed
all right you know what i'm gonna do
what i always threatened to do i am
legitimately going to
have to um give up on
keeping up so like if i missed your
question if it's back you may have to
ask it again
i'm sorry i can't keep up you guys are
hitting me you
you people i still use guys as like a
gender neutral in my head i'm tr i've
been trying to break that habit for
years
uh if they do make next to normal into a
movie would you go
see it uh uh
and how and if so how many times
depends on whether or not it's any good
uh i went 11 12 of my predictions wasn't
expecting
shit's creek to be such a massive sweep
yeah i heard about that i didn't watch
the emmys
i don't care i don't watch most of the
shows that were nominated
um after they made the first dark
crystal series they were 14 million
dollars in debt
well if you pay attention to netflix
they've never not been in debt
like serious debt like there was a whole
thing
two years ago or so
where like they took on a whole new dose
of loans and there were questions like
shouldn't you start paying back some of
your existing loans because
they're gonna come due like within the
next five years and you're loading up on
more debt
and netflix was all like no we know what
we're doing i honestly
in a couple of years when their original
startup loans come due
um they might be screwed
uh have you started accession yet if yes
where are you i
have not i did finish reading the last
thing that i needed to read
before starting that so it is my next
thing to start reading but i have not
started yet
uh favorite fifth doctor companion i
probably tegan maybe nissa
i don't love too many of them what are
your thoughts on jukebox
musicals for the most part i don't think
too highly of them they're
they're popcorn they're fun
fine uh do you watch the
stream debate faction of bread to people
like zander hall
vaushan to a lesser extent uh rgr not
on a regular basis now i like i'm
familiar with them especially um rgr
i was on her last stream talking about
jk rowling
so like i'm familiar with her but i i
came to be aware of her
because she actually reached out to me
after the blair white
thing happened uh earlier this year you
know to talk about that
so um i know her stuff more than the
others but like that whole
style isn't like
they do decent work but that style isn't
normally my pleasure viewing also if i'm
being honest i'm trying to cut down on
how much i watch you
youtube because i feel like i'm losing
too much time to it
because one of those days like oh just
one more video just one more video just
one more
just one just one oh three hours damn
now i gotta go to bed
what's your opinion of jk rowling's new
book um
nicest thing i can say about it is it's
a derivative idea that's been run into
the ground
it's been in thriller literature and
movies since the 1960s it's not a new
idea she's got no new spin on it so far
as i've been able to glean from the
reviews that i've read i will never read
the book itself
and that's me being my most generous
thing and not even bringing in
the real life thing she's been very
clear that she believes into the
conversation which just makes the entire
thing worse
there we go thoughts on the miniseries
i've never seen it front to back
i've seen clips mostly of tim curry
because i really like tim curry
but no i i haven't seen it end to end
i'm so proud to hear about your gender
pronoun and life decisions by the way
thank you jamie
uh would you talk about what made you
decide or
uh is there going to be a separate video
um i'm probably gonna do a video on it
on the vera wild channel about that
decision i actually
i want i need to try this week and maybe
next week
to shoot a number of topics for the vera
wild channel that i have been meaning to
get to
and this is what tends to happen is
they'll be
long dry they'll be months long dry
spells and then i'll shoot
three or four videos in succession and
release them over a couple months and
then i'll have another long
excuse me long dry spell and that's
that's typical of the cycle for that
channel
big finish has actually worked with
james marsters and amber benson
what do you think a big big finish did
buffy
um i mean you could
i don't know i mean like i
they could probably take a crack at just
about anything i don't that doesn't have
an immediate appeal to me personally
did you plan to watch anova homes
i know that name and i don't know why do
you practice
tai chi yes don't i come across as the
most zen
and centered person you have ever no no
i don't
i know nothing about tai chi i took
karate when i was a kid
for about a decade and i i got some
stuff out of it but like i don't
practice that anymore
i mean i've got muscle memory from that
um
but you know that's about it i've been
re-watching gotham i like to think
uh if i'd ever get to show run doctor
who it would have a similar tone dark
yet silly and the franchise is a
nutshell for me
hmm doctor who with a gotham
tone hmm
maybe maybe
are you a godfather no i'm not a
no
um like i
even people who like you know are close
enough to me that they would want that
for me like
i'm not a religious person
at all so um do you like
john behrman i bet he's kind and real
he's great
i love him i got to see him at
terrificon uh
last year and he was a delight i did get
to meet him i got i took selfies with
him it was wonderful he's a terrific
person
the most zen and center person someone
mentions the timeless child
ah
i doubt it but have you seen the netflix
film the babysitter
nope nola homes is a film about
sherlock's little sister
comedy i'm assuming
by the way have you seen lost i have
only seen
the first season of lost and then
everything else
after that has such um
[Music]
divisive and argued feelings especially
the ending that i'm like
i'm good i'm good what is your
profession you're looking at it
uh this is this is how i make my living
now which is still
so weird to say i say this i don't mean
streaming specifically but
like video creation
and podcasting and youtube and
everything that falls under the purview
of council of geeks is how i make my
living
now that's still weird to say
it's awesome but it's still weird
what are your thoughts on the watcher in
the woods i only know that
title but like i it's it's
like a family horror movie or something
was it a disney tv i don't know i know
i've heard the title i don't know it
i've never seen it
so enola homes is a film on netflix with
millie
bobby brown and sherlock holmes as
sherlock holmes younger sister oh good
she'll get to use her real accent
that'll be nice henry cavill and sam
clap in our homes of minecraft i don't
know sam claffin
helena bottom carter is their mother
helene
is helena bonham carter old enough to
pass for henry cavill's mother
is that where we're at now
[ __ ] i'm old god damn it
if season three of gotham had come out
now i imagine they
would have done their own version of the
batman who last storyline with bruce's
clone
i'm gonna take your word for that
because i i don't know what's going on
in the comics right now
what would you say is your most
unpopular opinion of doctor who
off the top my head the fact that i rank
david tennant as a middling doctor as
opposed to the best one ever seems to be
the one that most reliably gets people's
hackles up
uh do you like play or watch dnd i enjoy
playing it i have them for a long time
though
after a month of saving the universe and
playing d d i finally caught a live
stream
welcome doctor what is your favorite
color
um sort of a forest green
um most of the time but there are others
that i really like i like
deep colors i like a deep red i like a
deep purple
are you enjoying re-watching farscape
very much
um where we record several episodes
ahead of the
when they actually get released so um
i'm
i'm about i'm so close to getting to
watch the season one finale again and i
love the season one finale for farscape
so much it's so good
like we just scorpius just got
introduced in the
episodes um i just recorded the podcast
with jesse
on oh he's such a good villain i can't
wait till season two where we get harvey
if people don't know what i'm talking
about watch farscape
you'll thank me
what genre of music do you listen to i
don't follow
particular genres i mean ultimately i
tend to lean towards pop-ish
music but like i'm kind of all over the
place
should be a fairy godmother i mean it
could be
uh do you feel like the portrayal of
jack harkness is significantly different
from torchwood to doctor who
um i may have heard you say something
about the sorry if it's already said i
don't
think like here's what i'll say i don't
feel like torchwood jack is out of
character
they do feel like the same person but
he's not having any
fun on torchwood everything is dour and
sucks and everything's terrible and it
reflects on him
he's not having fun when he's on doctor
who is something closer to
you know the free-spirited swashbuckler
kind of character and he's just
more fun the characterization is not
substantively different because he still
has that sadness and that darkness about
him on doctor who
it's just not overpowering everything
else
the way it is on torchwood on towards
what he will only occasionally crack a
smile whereas on doctor who he will only
occasionally
frown or grimace so it's the same
components it's just the measurements
and the balance is different on each of
those shows
uh jumping down to the end again i've
nearly finished my audio series the
weirdest thing is that
it's a spin-off of a live-action show i
haven't finished writing yet
you are a busy busy person keep at it
uh so i keep getting distracted do you
see my question about the sandman
adaptation of audible i started
listening to it today
um i have just finished up 24 hours so
that's
john d in the diner and
i tell ya that was dark in the comics
hearing it in audio
[ __ ]
the batman who laughs isn't batman's
clone he's a dark multiverse version of
him where the joker finally pushed
batman to kill him
batman got jokerfied and yes it's cool
okay that's
i mean
if that's your bag
did you grow up with the animated series
reboot i grew up aware that it was a
thing that existed
i didn't watch it i thought your
favorite queen song would
uh either be bohemian rhapsody or we
will rock you no
i tend to lean more towards um
fat bottom girls or possibly who wants
to live forever
because i am both
frisky and sappy
hmm alternate universe moffett's
torchwood
that would be that would be an
odd thing to try and imagine do you like
enlightenment from season 20. i totally
have seen that one yet
haven't gotten to it watching gravity
falls loving it so far
keep it up that shows so much fun
oh you know super chat thank you uh
jolly hope i didn't butcher that um
do you think more fantasy in science
fiction movies would be better as
animation or stop-motion
uh yes
like i i really wish that particularly
in the us
and western entertainment
would get over the idea that animation
is for kids
because like i'll still check it out
when it comes out but i look at the fact
that netflix is doing a live action
adaptation of cowboy bebop and my
immediate thought is
why what is the benefit of doing that
live action
what do you gain like especially with
science fiction
and with fantasy and look animation
let's be clear
animation is not a cheap art form so
let's be clear about
that but that having been said
whatever it is you spend on animation
whatever your budget is that budget
will pay the same for whether you are
animating two people
talking in a room or animating a
completely alien landscape
it's all just drawing it's all just art
so i really really wish
that and like when i say animation for
me i mean 2d
look the the high end the 3d i i can
even love it i love moana i love
zootopia
i can get into those things but like i
miss
i miss looking forward to more 2d
i miss 2d films in general and
i would love to see something like um
something like wizards or
heck even something like titan ae which
isn't a great movie but i'm glad they
did it animated and i love the concept
and i like the world
i ah yeah i really would love that
what are your thoughts on force awakens
rogue one solo last jedi
rise of skywalker showed a lot of
promise probably
my favorite thing of the new things done
boring
frustrating and what the hell
if they were to do a tv adaptation of
league of extraordinary gentlemen which
i don't want to happen by the way
should they cast a trans male or trans
female as orlando
um the problem is
i only read the first two volumes of
league of extraordinary gentlemen so
orlando wasn't introduced yet and i
don't know how ellen moore writes that
character
so i mean like i feel
like anything other than cisgender would
be the way to go whether it
is trans male trans female
non-binary something like cis would
seem wrong to me but anything else i
would say go nuts
favorite queen song the show must go on
that is a good one
that is a very good one
excuse me i saw stray last week
he said he had a movie called watchmen
and all i can say
is the hallelujah scene had me dying
laughing the hallelujah
oh god watchmen that movie uh one of
these days
it's on my idea pile to do a deep dive
into that movie and and the things that
drive me absolutely
mad about that freaking movie
i really do need to check out the um the
hbo show though
because i've heard nothing but good
things
what are your thoughts on matilda
it's a thing that exists that's kind of
all i got
i'm aware of it um but i never read it
never watched the movie
it's a musical now too isn't it uh
i wouldn't be surprised if the uh
live-action cowboy bebop is done on
arrival keanu reeves tried for years
i mean like the big and usually the
thing that kills
most of these adaptations of especially
anime
is the budget it's the reason that the
live-action akira adaptation which first
of all
is a horrible idea just don't
but it's been it's stalled
repeatedly for about 20 years because
it's gonna cost so
much goddamn money and they'll never
make it back
like if battle angel lolita had done
really well
maybe they would have felt confident
going forward with akira and i actually
really
like battle angel lolita but
like it didn't make his money back
because it's so damn expensive
to try and recreate those visuals in
anything approximating live action
nicholas cage is he a good actor yes
he's also a guy with a lot of bills who
says yes to a lot of crap
just answer yes or no do you experience
non-transphobic
misogyny not
to any significant degree no
do you think bbc uh books should do
more with classic doctors the only
recent books were in
2012 13 14 1 2 3 and 4 which were
commissioned as deluxe for older readers
i mean i would like them to but much
like the hd
thing i suspect a lot of that has to do
with
the uh the marketing base that they are
trying to appeal to
doesn't buy those as much
so very should probably check the
discord thank you
carowind
um actually you know what the discord is
a whole lot of um
i don't really have a question going
into this
uh how are you holding up with
everything going on pretty well
um
[Music]
uh i don't have a question i'm just
excited to be there no questions
can't think of a question okay well that
was easy
uh what are your thoughts on james and
the giant peach i remember liking the
book when i was young
i saw the movie way back around when it
first came out
but um i haven't i've already visited
either in a long time
you'll love the hbo watchman it also
makes clear it comes from after the
comic rather than the movie well that's
good
have you seen the 1978 route back she
animated lord of the rings no i've been
meaning to forever
it's a good example of animated movie
for adults since underrated deserves
more attention
i mean like box she's a really
interesting filmmaker
not always a good one but an interesting
one
uh i read the first two volumes of
league of gentlemen for screenwriting
class where the movie was used
as an example of adaptation i don't
think you can
like i'm actually going to take issue
with your professor
for that class because i don't think you
can even
really consider that an adaptation
because
the comics weren't out yet when the
movie rights got
optioned the movie rights optioned
the concept he was alan moore was still
writing it when the script for the
movies were being written
so is it a bad adaptation yes but it's
not even really an adaptation of the
comics it's an adaptation of the concept
of the comics
so that's a really bad metric to try and
talk about failures and adaptation
because it's not it wasn't pulling on
finished results to write a script from
what's the name of the person who taught
you that seriously i want to send them
an email
that's a bad example
i may have spiked my drink
wish you prefer willy wonka in the
chocolate factory or charlie the
chocolate factory i gotta go with willy
wonka just because of gene wilder he's
so amazing that hopefully i'll be going
out on halloween me and two friends are
going as umbrella academy characters
um i have to be vania uh
because they're going as number five and
i can't stand the others
well i hope you have fun
uh favorite member of the peter noster
gang um
jenny i've nearly finished editing my
audio series oh no i read that comment
do you watch beavers and butthead nope
never have
never got into it not before not now
nope just nope
did you hear the news dark crystal was
cancelled yes yes i heard
uh like that first season's still really
good but
still i still got um
love that little guy don't quote me on
this but i heard somewhere that the last
episode of the 10th planet was lost
because the kids
show blue peter borrowed the tape to
show their regeneration and lost it
i mean with how everything else was lost
it wouldn't shock me have you read the
legends of river song i have
not uh if they were to make a movie
about your life who'd you want to play
you
me feed my ego let me act
uh have you seen the night manager with
tom hiddleston i haven't
i've heard good things but no i haven't
uh you watched the office
no never did really well i watched the
first season of the american version i'm
like yeah i don't
i don't love this the batman who laughs
was a cool design
but it's an idea that's fastest cell by
date i mean yeah
it's kind of my impression what are your
thoughts on dumb and dumber i
[ __ ] hate that movie
cheers favorite league of extraordinary
gentleman character
um god it's been so long since i've read
it
remember meaning
i remember meena meaning
meena like i found interesting it's kind
of
how many f-bombs is that now i know i'm
off the reservation a little bit this
time
i probably didn't use that phrase
train's gone off the rails maybe i don't
know
uh what are your thoughts on friends in
that 70s show
friends i've watched little bits and
pieces of it's
fun stated but it's fun um that 70s show
never got into it so glad
uh oh sorry that was a dr that was
directed to someone else
huh how long have you been doing f-bombs
on stream haven't been gone that long
i'm not regularly
i'm in a try to think of the right word
for the mood i'm in
um
i don't know i'm in some kind of mood
not a bad mood
i'm just
casual i don't know did you know that in
the doctor who comics
jenny from the doctor's daughter is
still alive have you already in the com
well i mean she's still alive in the
show too they just never brought her
back for another episode
have you have i read any of them nope uh
given the sandman audio adaptation
sorry hold on uh
is there any point in doing a tv version
also
have i got cynicism from you um short
answer
no not really
i still say they should do the tv
version animated
but um cynicism is catching
so dumb and dumber grease and ferris
bueller's day off any more well-loved
films you hate what about mean girls i
like mean girls
like to be clear i don't if we're
scaling on that
like i hate dumb and dumber and i hate
ferris wheeler's day off and i severely
dislike greece
i don't hate greece the way i hate those
other two
and mean girls is fun
are you ready for the pumpkin spice spam
the moment where high teaches griffin a
lesson is f'ed up yeah
i was okay with that when i read it in
my early twenties
i'm not sure how i feel i would feel
about um
reading that now did you watch the clone
wars thoughts no thoughts haven't
watched it
thoughts on wayne's world one and two i
remember liking the first one
significantly more
i've not seen either one in a long time
sorry to repeat the question
but have you seen the owl house i needed
to get onto disney plus
so no i want to
but i'm waiting
jenny did get her own sears on big
finish
not gonna lie wasn't that good well i
mean i wasn't planning to rush out and
try it anyways
like she's not a character who uh really
grabbed my attention
what do you think of the movie version
of league of extraordinary gentlemen i
actually don't mind it too much i think
it's
fine it's stupid it's kind of fun
i get i get some enjoyment out of it
is it is it representative of the source
material hell no
absolutely not as established but
uh titan comics is breathing new life
into doctor huna looks like
they might do stories with random
doctors at the very least conceptually
are you excited for this
i mean i might be if i read the comics i
don't i don't plan to start
but i'm happy for those who are reading
the comics
and i hope that they get their money's
worth how about that
okay i had to finish it off it had gone
cold
have you seen heather's yet if not it's
on hulu i don't have hulu and i
have no intention of ever watching that
thing
if someone feels gender fluid
do you think it's necessary to change
pronouns or name at almost 42
i feel weird answering to anything else
here's the thing to remember about any
form
of trans non-binary anything other than
cis
there are common practices
there's no rule book
you do not have to change your name
you do not have to change your pronouns
in order to be valid if your sense of
self
and your gender fluctuates your gender
fluid
whether you use different pronouns
whether you request different pronouns
whether you use a secondary name
whether you only ever use the name you
were assigned at birth that does not
invalidate who you are in your sense of
self
that is still valid no matter what again
there are
the common practices and there will be
others
who are going to be gatekeeping about
this and so and say that you're not
really whatever you claim to be unless
you do those things but those people are
wrong
they're wrong they can't know
who you are and how you feel only you
can know that
if this is who you are then that is
valid
you don't have to change your name if it
doesn't feel right
don't do it if it does do
but there's no rule book there's no
checklist
of things you must do in order to
be gender fluid non-binary trans no
that is not how this works
finally watch saving mr banks enjoyed it
a lot more than i thought it would that
was a pretty
good movie yeah i just saw scott pilgrim
versus the world
and also kick ass and found out their
movie rights were bought when the first
comics came out
yeah yeah now
i haven't seen either one in a while but
i i don't i know i don't think as highly
of scott pilgrim versus the world that
has
a lot of geeks mainly because i hate the
ending
oh where was i
the good doctor oh oh dear the good
doctor was my favorite doctor who book
at one point
it was great to hear your opinion on
especially since i weirdly never noticed
that its plot was a cliche
i hope i didn't ruin it for you like
that's think even
even when i can't stand something
i don't intend to ruin it for the people
who like it i don't want to take that
away from you
but man did that rub me up the wrong way
oh i seldom finished doctor who series
12. i sort of stopped after orbiting 55
not because it was the worst episode
but i just lost motivation to keep
seeing it for some reason
that's your call um orphan 55 is the low
point of series 12 in my opinion so like
that's as bad as it's going to bit a bit
get
i couldn't decide if i was going to say
b or get so i went with bet
mmm would you rather play the doctor or
the master
oh
really depends on my mood
oh i could go back and forth on that
because the problem is like as someone
with aspirations as an actor i know how
i would play either one of them
and i would really love the chance to do
it
um
like seriously when this plague lifts if
somebody wants to try and
line me up for fan productions i'm there
just saying uh
the league movie ended the careers of
both the director and the leading man
it was pretty damaging it didn't end
sean connery's career
he just chose to stop after that if he'd
wanted to keep making movies he could
have he just hit his breaking point
steve norrington yeah it did kind of
kill him
i've been staring at it for many videos
but i have to ask what is the yellow
stuff toy behind you
that is a toucha coma
from a ghost in the shell and i would
take it down but it would knock down
like five things for me to do so so i'm
gonna leave
that fellow right where they are
i watched your 10 worst angel episodes
to be honest i quite liked the episode
about lauren and the casino and the
episode in italy
some people do and they just don't
really do much for me
have you heard of the band chameleon
circuit i feel like i have
um but i don't know a ton
about them i know their songs are based
on
doctor who stuff but that's about all i
know i don't think i've ever listened to
them
i saw an online live uh riffing on the
air on the last airbender it was well
deserved
i saw so many videos on that flop that i
was anticipating
uh that i was anticipating
the most infamous scenes like the rock
throw yeah i haven't seen that one
either but i have seen a lot of
dissections of it
so yeah
alan moore is probably going to be the
first guy to be pissed off at being
thanked at an emmy acceptance speech
i think you'd have to
you'd have to prove he actually watched
the emmys first i would be shocked if he
did
like he won't know that he was banked at
an emmy's until like
some nosy reporter who tracks him down
to ask him that and then he's gonna put
a hex on that reporter because the man's
a freaking warlock
not saying that is an insult that's like
a fact
i really want you to do a collab with
yourself from a few years ago
oh that that would that would be
interesting wouldn't that
okay
you can spice my pumpkin any day
cheeky thank you for the super chat
so my friend a trans guy gate keeps the
hell out of his experience and says
it's the only valid one dysphoria and
that gender fluid people don't exist how
do i talk to them about it honestly i
don't know
i i don't i don't know how to get
through to people who hardline that
opinion
it's easier to get through to someone
who is
parroting that opinion because they
picked it up from someone else who they
assumed was an authority
so you know lots of online pundits
a lot of their followers and supporters
are parroting what those people said and
it's not necessarily a belief that they
hold in their hearts
but they're assuming that the person
they heard it from knew what they were
talking about and maybe if you can show
them another way
they'll start to open up not always but
sometimes but when someone is that
gatekeeping based off their
own experience as opposed to
you know something that they picked up
elsewhere i don't know
i i don't know how you address that
i wish i had an answer for you
how do we know this plan would work we
had a spy on the inside that's right
hercules mulligan oh
that songs from that soundtrack have
been coming up on my um
on the mixes i i listen to when i go
running
an awful lot
some of them work really well non-stop
works satisfied works quite well as a
running song
actually i was surprised by that one
uh
there were some others i can't oh room
where it happened
that one was good ever had one episode
completely ruin a show
don't mention torchwood for me it was
the season two finale
of the good doctor i don't know that
show particularly
i mean i will let you know once i get to
the end of
lovecraft country but it's possible that
one scene has ruined that show for me
we'll see
uh would you rather have a fist fight
with luther
archery contest with diego gossip
spreading contests with allison drinking
contests with klaus
hunt down uh number five or
piss off vinya let's go drinking with
klaus like i'll lose the drinking
contest but
we'll have fun i don't know if this is
too political
oh boy but how but how do you think the
election will go
for early voting to the final fight also
attendant is fantastic
trump is going to contest the outcome
they don't declare that he is a victor
within 48 hours of election day
he's going to contest the results
that's just the thing he's going to do
so this is why i am dreading
the election because even if
you know the side that i would prefer
wins
um
it's still not going to be pleasant
and then so let me let me put it this
way
it's possible for trump to win again
despite
his numbers being in the absolute toilet
because of
how the stupid goddamn electoral college
works
stupid thing that we need to get rid of
because it's
archaic and outdated and there's no
reason for it to still exist but it'll
never get changed because it's that
system that put the people in power
where they are and they don't want to
change it because it's what got them
there
but anyway because of that
stupidity it's possible that he might
win again
that having been said
if he wins and
the republican party picks up seats
like in the senate or even the house
you know have higher numbers than they
currently do
i don't know what i'm gonna do
because that will indicate
that
this country
has become something that i may not want
to
take part in anymore
i just i i have a very
hard time
wrapping my head around
anyone who can look at trump
and what he's been doing and how he's
been behaving
things that he has said the things that
he has done
and goes that's what i want my country
to be
and i'm not saying that you need to love
joe biden i don't love joe biden
honestly i wanted literally any nominee
other than joe biden
but
how can trump be what we are
i really want to do a fan production
with you playing the doctor me as the
master my scheme is to force you to
watch and sing along to doctor in
distress
you are obsessed my friend
who's your favorite character to cosplay
as oh
oh that is a tough call
i mean like the actual outfit i kind of
i kind of really like
the 13th doctor's outfit it's just
wonderfully casual there are some other
ones that i think i look really good in
but like they're
restrictive or a lot of work like i
think i look great as poison ivy but
damn that's a lot of work getting in
that freaking
outfit
ah let's see lady and the [ __ ] are 101
dalmatians i grew up on lady and [ __ ]
and i don't think it's a better movie
but i have more more nostalgia for it
have you heard jodie whitaker's cover of
yellow by coldplay
i have not amazing singing voice as to
john bearman well john bearman i knew
that i knew
he could sing ah so that
that was never a question
apparently alan moore started writing
radioactive man
and made a heroin a headache
non-radioactive man
this is a reference to the al mohr
simpsons episode oh yeah i forgot about
that
i actually have seen that it's one of
the last simpsons episodes i saw
uh do you watch last week tonight with
john oliver yes i do
yes i do and i like it very much uh
everybody
give it up for america's favorite
fighting frenchman yep
good stuff the fact that dorian gray
crumbles to dust when he's shown his
painting shows that they didn't even
research the original source material
for the characters league well big
yeah there's that were you a cheerleader
in high school no
so here's my interest in sports
down here somewhere
if you really think about the real
villain of hamilton is alexander himself
well
[Laughter]
look electoral college is so racist and
unfortunately we'll never go the
electoral thing
the electoral college is a lot of things
uh most of them undemocratic
that's the thing the electoral college
it wasn't created with the intent
of subjugating the
um the electoral process it was
in many ways a logistical necessity
at the point of the country's formation
it is kept in place
for some shady
bs reasons though
uh will you go out as alexander hamilton
for halloween well no
no see the thing is like as much as i
like that show
and i like those songs like i would
never try and be any of the characters
because
like even though the real people were
yes white
um like that portrayal
the the fact that they're played by
people of color is so fundamental i
like relay i could only ever be king
george
you'll be back uh we need ozymandias to
make a giant squid
you don't need the squid
if they are the gatekeepers who are the
key masters
i was
19 years old by the time i realized the
sexual implication of the key master and
the gatekeeper
in ghostbusters
ah i mean like i i knew that they hooked
up
like just the names
what is it what do you do with a key you
stick it in a hole
right
my country's going down the drain to
right-wing populism and anti-lgbt
zones i hope usa can fight this trend
well see
here's what's really frustrating uh anna
and
this is the case in most
countries at least any time i look into
it
um
the actual people the majority of the
populists
don't want these right-wing things but
they've managed to get the power
through various
questionable means or writing
certain ways or fear-mongering or what
have you but when you actually break it
down by the issues
one by one and ask specifically on those
issues
most people in most western countries
favor the more liberal option or at
least they do not favor the
extreme right things that are being
implemented in a lot of places
so it's why people like trump love to
use the phrase well you know people are
saying a lot of people are saying never
numbers
never percentages never statistics
because they don't back them up
never have in response to trump
uh do you know what hate looks like game
he looks like a dalek immediately sprang
to mind
have you seen infinity train nope it's
on my watch list but i have
not
i own 13 coats and a few of her shirts
they're so comfy and great to wear it
they really
are what are your thoughts on calling
ballinger ak miranda sings i have no
thoughts i don't know who that is
sometimes all you have are bad choices
but you still have to choose yeah
yeah yeah
i'm gonna have to wrap up soon i think
oh i need to lay down i i did a lot of
driving today because like i mentioned i
went to go saw a friend so my back isn't
very happy with me
have you listened to wolf 359 it's an
audio drama
podcast i have not listened to that one
i actually hadn't even heard of that one
usually when people ask me stuff i'm
like no but i've heard of it i haven't
even heard of that one
not gonna lie jody's outfit and
screwdriver have grown on me i still
hate the tardis interior
i don't love that tardis interior i do
dislike how little we
have seen um of
the of that taurus interior it doesn't
feel like a home base
the way the other tardis is do it just
feel it feels more like a
vehicle instead of a home and that
annoys me
uh are there any songs that remind you
of dr houshira or other favorite fandoms
what's your opinion on whether or not
jack is the face of bo
well thank you very much bookworm like
he is
like what is the argument for him not
being the face of beau i i get this
question every now and then do you think
he really is like well
yes there's evidence pointing to the
fact that he is
and i have yet to have anybody
um point out to me the evidence that he
isn't
other than they just don't like the idea
so yeah um
i don't know that i tend to associate
music strongly from where it actually
comes from so it's pretty uncommon
for me to have a song
that reminds me of something else i
i do much stronger associations with
things that i can directly link to it
you know people who i know who also like
it people who i've heard
listen to it with the movie or tv show
that i've actually seen it on
but i i don't
my brain just doesn't work that way
excuse me uh do you have vivid dreams
that
seem real about your favorite show uh or
make your own characters for the
universe
um no not generally i'll have vaguely
influenced dreams
like i'll i'll have a dream and then
i'll wake up and i realize
oh i had that dream because i watched
blah recently but it's not a direct
recreation
kind of thing more like bits and pieces
love your singing voice thank you
there's a squid i've got a jaw of dirt
it's the jar of dirt going to help
you don't want it give it back no then
it helps
the squid is in the hbo series yes i've
heard
sorry i'm just hanging up
ah thank you carolyn for dealing with uh
with that unpleasantness
good jumping on it suddenly vote saxon
doesn't look so bad
no comment have you seen community
i've heard good things but i never did
get around to it when you have an amazon
wishlist for a rorschach cosplay but you
don't have any sims to buy
stuff um
i don't think i'd ever cosplay rorschach
because like it's not because rorschach
isn't a good character rorschach is a
great character
i hate the lionizing of roshack you're
not supposed to like rorschach
rorschach is a terrible terrible person
you are not supposed to think he's cool
it's a little bit like tyler durden like
you're not supposed to like him
ah um do you have even daydreams that
seem real
uh daydreams uh
not really my
my adhd brain is too scatter shot to
create something
that vivid like just in front of my eyes
i laugh at the idea of woodrow wilson
looking at trump and going i don't know
this guy
[Music]
well then another reason to dislike
torchwood was that jack was meant to
appear
and a good man goes to war and be
beheaded by the monks but bearman was
busy filming
miracle day i mean i'm not sure i
necessarily needed that
i would have depended on execution
uh the face of beau implies jack ran out
of horniness at some point and that's
weird to me does it though
because uh this broadcast in
uh an earlier and the first time they're
on satellite five so
the long game that if you listen says
that the face of beau is pregnant
so it sounds to me like he's still just
a horny head in a jar
to me i mean everybody's gotta slow down
eventually
jack can't be the face of bo because the
face of beau is actually the ronnie is
the timeless child who is my dad
that went in a weird direction
it always does when you tie it back to
your dad
all right i i really should wrap it up
but now i'm determined to try and catch
up
that dream question reminds me of
something you were in a dream of mine
recently you are sarcastically talking
about star wars
me sarcastic well i never
good day
was the last uh who was the last person
as sweetie or
any term of endearment um i don't know i
saw liz on my way home
probably called her something along
those lines
some people ask why i don't do sports
it's actually because i suffer from a
condition
uh i can't be arsed
uh i don't even like moving don't even
listen to sad music
in case i'll be moved that's um
that's really holding to that is nardole
the blue bald guy from series five and
six
uh no no he's not i used to have a blue
face i
yes i know but no he's i don't
i do not that doesn't line up
personalities don't match
at all
who's your favorite comedian i mean
ultimate favor probably still
um george carlin
but i love eddie izzard i love hannah
gatsby
um there's some good ones out oh john
mulaney i have a lot of fun with
ever seen cabaret stage or movie version
i have not
and the video game detroit become human
you play an android
and the lion is uh will you join your
people or rise against your creators
what's worse than
choosing between two evils
rising against your oppressors is not an
evil
bite me david cage
to be honest that means jack has been
pregnant three times yeah that sounds
about right
horny and the jar is how i feel these
days that's a mood
oh yeah finally got the dvd of the
constantine series
have fun i love the last jedi just my
monthly reminder
good for you
uh given how amazing they made jacoby
i'm curious to see how big finish does
dawn sims master
uh hopefully well warmaster's so good
i finished like claudius i'm now
watching jeremy brett sherlock home
series because he's the best
he is very good
uh what are your thoughts on the shining
never read the book movie is drastically
overrated
it's not very good
now we need to see the body parts of
beau that's an adult series
yahtzee kroshaw's reviews of david cage
games always make me laugh
yes me too cake or death
uh cake please
so oh oh i do need to wrap up oh my
back's not happy
i've been sitting in the uh in a car way
too long today
so um thank you everybody
uh for tuning in i hope that you had a
good time
nice try ben um
i'll stay till the end but just remember
you're valid you are loved
we may be the council but you're the
reason we keep coming
thank you very much i know you've
described yourself as an anti-capitalist
before is there a specific ideology you
subscribe to i'm a market socialist
no there isn't really because i'm too
lazy to research all of them
i just see too many let me put it this
way
i could get behind properly regulated
capitalism
unfettered capitalism no pack that in
uh but i hope everybody is
well i hope you stay safe
it's uh it's still a wild time
out there not always in a good way but
be well be kind be safe
and please remember that you are
beautiful
you are valid you are loved
you are the council i just run the
meetings and until next time my comedy